[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the one basket he made
in six attempts at mr lillard he's been
doing it a long time
that one emphatic
[Applause]
and they played together
damien trying to get it rolling takes it
strong with a tomahawk dick hannah
dealerships be leaving nice
here's some of that energy the lane
clears
dame eyes the rim goes straight up
leticia looking for the handoff damian
lillard steps in front he's got it he'll
go the distance and finger roll it up
and in and the blazers
spin move quickness
do you hear how much terry stops his
yelling run
dave will right into about a 35-footer
against oklahoma city and to get away to
that four-game trip where was that one
from
martin speaking of good but cj mccollum
still a little inconsistent to start
this season getting offense going
lillard with the blowbox
[Applause]
got allen on the switch up top a flurry
of ball moves between the wickets step
back and launch that three surveys the
scene he's got five he's got four he
works on dinwiddie
step back at three got it damian lillard
with a triple
four tenths of a second remaining for
the next it's halfway through
the threat of the drive gets you running
towards the rim
3.6 to shoot very long there
blocked by lillard he comes down a loose
ball foul on atlanta
tend to shoot little and outside with
eight to shoot long way from home with
six there you go drives it sidesteps
into the lead cuts to the window and
laid it in
and i like these matchups kevin when
he's going against a two guard who
if he doesn't bring his a game you could
get embarrassed on the other end
dame says get that out of here point i
figured out something
was going on but like dame said he
spends and one count that to the
free-throw line right on time paul does
one of those things they run a lot of
screen and roll this is that action
right there up top between lillard and
whiteside
and that's what you don't want is that
skipped pass
as mccullum seen that by the way the
spiesfield house
oh my goodness it sums up indiana
basketball
that's in indianapolis indiana's white
side scores on the dump down
tie it at six all dame working on corey
joseph
spins into the lane to the glass and
laid it in powerfully
going to the hole blazers will bring it
the other way
it's important though that the blazers
don't overlook this
gotta have this one just to kick things
off crossover step back give me three
i'm not sure what happened wayward
toliver back outside dame reloads
that's the way you get her done wow
shabazz is flying out there today
so you take a 6-8 wing man out of the
mix along with scalabi sierra
lillard outside for three guys
[Applause]
damn trying to shake javon carter marks
a three up and in
damiana lillard red hot and rolling
we just went through this a couple weeks
ago
the guy is so good though that's why
coach schatz wanted hassan lane back off
the screen
and lowry bit coming off the screen
lower the three
the blazers have tied this game at 99 on
another three-point shot
and once it gets into dame's hands he's
throwing money at the rim
dirk checking his watch here in front of
us
and damien the hornets have put 43
points on the board in the period
a three from graham back iron rebound
trip up the game
at the buzzer
[Applause]
wrestles the rebound away from hardaway
junior it's always a good sign when
assange is over there
just snatching rebounds away from people
dave comes off the white side screen
rocks into a three assisted by cj the
half minutes ago coming up the american
express halftime report what
three lillard
did he knock that down from great bend
one dribble one dribble over half court
and i raised he was in bend oregon
wasn't he when he shot a picture look at
that
man oh man that was a beauty
difference of two and a half seconds
game clock and shot clock
willard working on perks dancing free
a free god
this is great defense here by perks i
mean there's not more you can do
and that's a clear three and that ties
the game
and lillard has 54 and he's got
10 threes got seven to fire on top de
lillard fumbles it away
shot clock at three has the defense in
front
long shot by dame right down the hatch
look at this look at this shot here shot
clock running down
from the a and motor there's now 10 of
17 tonight
berlin scores here i can see a timeout
here from parliament
oh that's a free it's an 11 nothing run
you're right carlyle calls time
off into the corner ariza back out on
top today
nice handle behind the back flips the
right side for the two-hand jam
lillard pulls up just past half point
portland eight turnovers in the quarter
helping helping the case here but look
at that
they did have a four-game skid they have
won three or four
since there's littlert again from the
logo
that's twice you cannot stop
damien lillard right now those damien
signature adidas [ __ ] once again
the rookie very active lillard on the
steel fires away at two for one and hits
the three-pointer
damian lillard but but i when i look out
at
what you would want your nba player to
look at oh my goodness
wow damian lillard
frustration but puts his head down
attacks in the paint area
lillard count it and the foul damian
lillard
lighting it up here at staples center
ties the game and a chance for a
four-point play
really as a defender you're chasing hard
on damian his initial defense was part
of that
[Music]
lillard that is a deep one he got it
we don't have the tape measure but these
kinds of
shots every kind of shot imaginable but
how about the efficient use of the
screen
has now won sixth straight how about
toronto gets win number 13
straight tonight nick nurse doing an
outstanding job as
lillard launches and connects
again you know their focus is taking
away the three
so two go to the ball but bogey steps
away
to recover thinking joe's fine you're
never fine
they'll spin away and miss the fader and
the rebound recovered by lillard
dame head up and scanning looking for
the opportunities
takes it to the cap with a left hand
left-hand jam for lillard
legal in 12 states cap to hit somebody
with this kind of in and out
and then the lefty dunk